because there's a bunch of people been
reaching out to me
trying to get me to write a book which
is ridiculous why there
there's people who are brilliant folks
like you like jordan peterson
that i think have a lot of knowledge to
share with the world okay
i think what i feel i can contribute to
the world in terms of impact
is to build something okay
meaning like engineering stuff okay like
a book
it has to be engineered and i'm not
using it loosely you have to engineer a
book
no for sure i what i mean is like
literally a product with programming and
artificial intelligence involved that's
i want to build a company i want to
because i have a few ideas that i feel
i'm equipped and it has to do with your
like intuition about the way you can
build a better world
you individually like what can you add
to the world that's a positive thing
and for me i feel like the
maximal thing i can add to the world is
at least to attempt
to build products that would add more
love
in the world and like so i want to focus
on that the danger of the book
for me or any kind of writing
and even this podcast is a little bit
dangerous for me it's like
it's fun for sure it's
it's fun it's like it takes you into
this place where you start thinking
about the world you start enjoying and
playing with ideas you start
and like just your book on um a dear
reader
uh but also then you write like
clearly you and i probably think
similarly in the sense that
you did a lot of work yes this next book
is
killing me yeah as you mentioned often
it's clear
like uh on your youtube channel which
i'm a fan of
you often it just comes out like you
mention all of these books that you're
reading it just comes through
you that you're suffering through this
and you've
it changes you and it's clear
that you're thinking deeply about the
world because of this book and i feel
like if you do that
that's like uh when i was when i first
came to this country i
read the book the giver i need to read
it again it's like
it uh the red pill thing is it changes
you
in where you can never be the same
person again and i feel i feel about a
book in that same way
the moment you write a book of course it
depends on the book
i could also just write uh like in my
field a very technical book no that's a
terrible idea
yes but that that's okay that doesn't
really change you that's just like
sharing information
but like something where you're like how
do i think about this world
can you just leave that behind you i get
it dude it's
it's being pregnant there's it never
escapes your brain i'm telling you
you're absolutely right
you